an important signature for you ah him
live but more so for the german soccer
association it wanted to avoid a repeat
of the last World Cup when rumors about
Louvre future dominated the run-up this
is an Angus pieces aha we work very well
together but we're not set in our ways
fun our relationship is very
professional annulment Fatone we have
huge faith in him and the atmosphere is
very constructive get baked you all team
lurve has been part of the Germany setup
for 11 years now he began as the
right-hand man to Jurgen Klinsmann
responsible for strategy and tactics it
was after the 2006 world cup that he
took the helm despite Klinsmann's
guiding Germany to third place he
decided not to extend his contract
Joakim lurve took over he appointed
hansi flick as his assistant together
they developed a modern attacking style
that brought Germany on in leaps and
bounds they moved up the FIFA rankings
to number two in the world defeated in
just 15 of 99 matches germany qualified
easily for two european championships
and two world cups but lurve hasn't won
any titles yet now he's got his eyes on
the biggest prize of all the world cup
in brazil next year but a failure to
live up to expectations would spell the
end so did to fall into outside and if
we got knocked out in the first round
and head home without a point I think
both sides will recognize there's no
point continuing 400 you hop night we
have a good team will go into this world
cup well prepared but to discuss now
what amounts to success we're not
thinking about that right now Muhammad
said see women keine gedanken there will
be one big change after the World Cup
assistant coach Hansie flick has already
decided he'll be moving on